- There was a time when the universe was expanding
so rapidly that parts of it were moving apart
from each other faster than the speed of light.
That time is right now. A lot of people make
a big deal out of the fact that during inflation,
right after our universe burst into existence,
the whole universe was expanding faster than
light. Now, while that is true, it kind of
implies that the universe doesn't normally
do that, and it does. I mean, if you pick
two points far enough apart in our universe,
you can always find ones that are moving apart
from each other faster than light. That is
simply due to all of the expanding space in
between. So our universe is now and has always
been expanding faster than the speed of light.
But doesn't this violate Einstein's special
theory of relativity that says nothing should
be able to move faster than light? Actually,
no. Relativity says nothing can move through
space faster than light, but that doesn't
stop space itself from expanding however it
likes. Now, it was Hubble in the late 1920s
who made the observations of the night sky,
which led us to see that our universe is expanding.
The further out in space he looked, the faster
the objects were moving away from us. So imagine
a point so far out there that the average
recession velocity is the speed of light.
I mean, if you think about it, it's going
to be the same distance in every direction.
So that would form a sphere which we call
the Hubble Sphere. Everything beyond that
sphere is moving away from us faster than
the speed of light. So common sense would
say we would never be able to see the light
from those objects because of how fast they're
moving away from us. But in fact, this is
not true. We can see those objects. To understand
how this could work, picture a galaxy beyond
our Hubble Sphere. It's receding faster than
light, it's in a super luminal region of space
from our perspective. So any light that emits
in our direction, will actually be moving
away from us as time goes on. Well that doesn't
sound very promising. But due to the accelerating
expansion of space, our Hubble Sphere is actually
getting bigger. And if it gets bigger faster
than that light can get away, then at some
point that light is going to travel from a
super luminal region of space into a subluminal
region of space, and so it can start making
progress towards us. So we can detect it,
so we can see that distant galaxy, which is
of course now even further beyond our Hubble
Sphere, but we can see its light. We can detect
that it's there. This is remarkable. In fact,
all of the photons we now receive from the
first 5 billion years of the universe, they
were all emitted in regions of space that
were traveling, at the time, faster than the
speed of light relative to us. The objects
that emitted them were, are, and always have
been moving away from us faster than the speed
of light. But their light has entered our
Hubble Sphere and had enough time to reach
us, and so we can see them. So the observable
universe is larger than our Hubble Sphere.
It's actually limited by what's called the
particle horizon. That is based on the amount
of time light has had to travel towards us
since the beginning of time, that is 13.8
billion years ago as far as we can tell. Now
because the universe has been expanding and
that expansion has been accelerating, things
are much further out than 13.8 billion light
years away. I mean, the observable universe
has a radius of over 46 billion light years.
The diameter is about 93 billion light years.
That is a huge volume of things that we can
see. And 13.8 billion years ago, everything
in that volume and everything beyond it that
we can't see would have been compressed into
a tiny infinitesimally small point that we
call the singularity. Actually, no. I mean,
that would be true if the universe is finite.
But if the universe is infinite, and it kind
of looks like it is, then it was always infinite.
So the big bang would have happened literally
everywhere. But if the universe has always
been infinite, then what is it expanding into?
Well, it doesn't have to expand into anything.
I mean, it can expand into itself. That's
the thing about infinity. You never run out
of it. This episode of Veritasium was supported
by audible.com, a leading provider of audiobooks
with over 150,000 titles in all areas of literature,
including fiction, non-fiction, and periodicals.
This week I wanted to recommend the book Hitchhiker's
Guide To The Galaxy. It's one of my favorites
and it's a classic of the science genre. You
know, people often ask me, why is the number
42 on the Veritasium logo? And that's because
it's the answer to the ultimate question of
life, the universe, and everything. So if
you haven't read this book yet, you should
definitely check it out, and in fact, you
can download it for free by going to audible.com/veritasium,
or you can pick any other book of your choosing
for a one month free trial. So I want to thank
Audible for supporting me and I want to thank
you for watching.